في ردود الفعل رحبت رئاسه الفلسطينيه
بتصويت الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
لصالح فلسطين
ان هذا التصويت دليل على وقوف العالم اجمع
الى جانب الشعب الفلسطيني وحقوقه
تحت القانون وانت تحاسب على جرائمها
المستمره وعلى العالم تحمل مسؤولياته
وتطبيق قررت الشرعيه الدوليه
مشيرا الى ان القياده الفلسطينيه ستستمر
بالانضمام الى الهيئات
والمؤسسات الدوليه لحمايه الحقوق
الفلسطينيه
بالاجماع الدوليه والتصويت على الممارسات
الاسرائيليه التي تمسح حقوق الشعبي
الفلسطيني
فتوى قانونيه من محكمه العدل الدوليه
الى انه سيفتح حقبه جديده
لمساءله اسرائيل
وفي الخبر العاجله الذي يظهر على شاشتنا
حركه حماس تقول ما دامت الولايات المتحده
تتصرفك شركه للاحتلال
وتوفر له الغطاء فستبقى القرارات حبرا على
ورق هذا طبعا رد فعل حماس على القرار الذي
تبنته الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده كذلك
استعرضنا ردود فعل السلطه الفلسطينيه حول
هذا القرار لكن اننا نستطلع المزيد مع
مراسلاتنا من رام الله جباره البديري كذلك
كانت قد توفرت همم ردود فعل اسرائيليه
جيفارا
بالفعل هناك غضب اسرائيلي كبير رغم ان
اليوم السبت لم يصدر قرار يعني بيان رسمي
ولكن واضح ان هناك غضب اسرائيلي وارتياح
فلسطيني كامل وفق مصادر فلسطينيه مطلعه
مارست الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واسرائيل حتى اللحظات الاخيره كل اشكال ما
وصفت بانواع الابتزاز والتنمر على الدول
لعدم التصويت على هذا القرار وبالتالي
اعتبر هذا الامر هو الاهم بدايه بافشال
المحاولات الاسرائيليه والامريكيه لعدم
تمرير القرار في الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده الامر الاخر اهميه هذا القرار انه
سيصدر الان عن اعلى هيئه قضائيه في
العالميه محكمه العدل همم الدوليه المطلوب
الان هو فتوى الشرعيه بمعنى انها اعلى من
فكره
استشاري او قضائي او هذا ثاني قرار يصدر
عن محكمه العدل الدوليه بعد القرار الذي
كان قد صدر قبل سنوات بان جدار الفصل
العنصري هو جدار غير قانوني ايضا اهميه
هذا القرار بانه ياتي في اليوم الثاني
لتشكيل الحكومه الاسرائيليه التي توصف على
كثير ومن قبل كثيرين بانها حكومه الاكثر
التطرفا وانها هذه الفتوه ستواجه على
الاقل تسعه بنود من برنامج الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الذي يقوم على توسيع
الاستيطان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه في
الجولان في النقب وتحديدا ايضا في القدس
وهذا القرار كان الفلسطينيون و تحديدا
الدبلوماسيه الفلسطينيه تعمل عليه منذ خمس
سنوات واحتاج الامر على الاقل سنتين
للوصول الى السؤال الذي يجب ان يطرح ليتم
تمريره من قبل الجمعيه العامه هو ما هي
الانتهاكات استمرار الانتهاكات
الاسرائيليه والاحتلال في في فلسطين وحق
الفلسطينيين في تقرير المصير والوضع
القانوني لمدينه القدس من خلال التشريعات
وبالتالي هذا هو اهميه هذا القرار وهمم
الزام محكمه العدل الدوليه من قبل الجمعيه
العامه معناها انه لحظه صدور الفتوى فعل
على الدول في العالم الالتزام بذلك هذا
معناه تغيير في السياسات اتجاه دوله
فلسطين التي هي الدوله غير مراقب في الامم
المتحده والتعامل بشكل مختلف ونسكر ايضا
انه ياتي ايضا في اخر يوم في السنه
وبالتالي سيعتبر انه في عام 2002 2020 ولم
يتم حتى تاجيله الى يوم الغد الامر انه
ياتي ايضا بعد ساعات من صدور همم بيان من
ممثل الاتحاد الاوروبيه حول حمايه الكنائس
المسيحيه الوضع القانوني والوضع الق في
القدس اذا هناك تحركات دوليه اتجاه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده ولكن الفتوى
الشرعيه من قبل المحكمه معناه قرار ملزم
الان لجميع دول العالم باجبار اسرائيل على
وقت كل تلك الانتهاكات بما ينص على انه
ايضا نذكر ان هذا هو القرار الخامس عشر
منذ 20 عاما الذي يصدر عن المحك عن
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده لصالح
فلسطين اضافه بالطبع الى كل القرارات التي
صدرت عن اليونسكو مجلس حقوق الانسان
وبالتالي همم حبوب الخارشيه الفلسطينيه
وايضا اا امين سر اللجنه التنفيذيه لمنظمه
التحرير شكرا وايضا الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
بان هناك الان يعني خلق لاسرائيل من كافه
الاتجاهات الدبلوماسيه
رام الله